IS 0-FER THREE.
>> Glenn: AND THAT WAS HID.
ENDED LAST SEASON AS A MEMBER
OF THE KINGS AND LOOK
MVP CONVERSATION. KNICKS.
>> Doris: LET'S WATCHNINE
POINTS.
THIS MAN.
OKEYDOKE.
KLEBER, DOWN IT GOES.E LAID IT .
YEAH, IT IS  THE
OPPOSITE TEAM. THE DRIBBLE
AT SOME POINT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LOT OF
MOVEMENT HER THE FINISH.
>> Hubie: LOVES A TIME-OUT. DEF.
STANLEY JOHNSON.
UP IN THE AIR, HOW ABOUT  SHOT
HALF.
ALLEN MISSES A THREE.
GIANNIS G
THIRD ON T TEAM ON KAT.
>> K KITTLE USAGED WORKS ON HOL
SHOVELS TO MOBLEY -- OH, BIG FE
THUNDER FROM T
THE LEAD. THERE IS ONE FOR R
OVER STEWART.OFF TWO
FEET.
WATCH THIS.
AHEAD, KUMIMI
COCK IT BACK AND THROWBANE
I DON'T BELIEVE WHAT I HAVE  OF